No Thanksgiving it's coming out yes
Thanksgivings coming up we don't have
the greens and the macaroni and the
dressings what what's your opinion on
Turkey I'm into Turkey what's your
opinion on Turkey's that's not my animal
choice if I'm gonna have like a zoo you
ever met one have met a turkey yeah no I
have not
would you like to know oh my god oh
that's actually I just didn't know it
I'm finna cry just a real one Oh turkey
no come out flying and crazy
I want hurt or heat the turkeys name is
Captain Turk oh how delightful
Oh captain Turk I'm oh boy Oh didn't
didn't see you there do you come around
here often there's nothing to be scared
of you're the fastest turkey in the
world it's a boy say handsome young boy
what's a turkey call Oh Tory doing try
that like Dennis I gobble gobble oh
sorry
oh yeah now we got to turn towards
camera oh whoa
hands quick Oh shake it off you got some
Taylor Swift going on oh my god he's
amazing
his bird looks like a 50 year old man
would you like to take a selfie with me
look at the camera Turkey hey yo captain
oh he looks not happy and I look super
stoked there we go
Happy Thanksgiving looking at cat new
Turk do you believe that this is perhaps
a more proper symbol of our strong
nation no I like the eagle so we're
gonna keep that we're gonna keep the
bald eagle the bald eagle now we're just
gonna eat the turkey yep okay poop there
poop there and where the turkey stepped
in it and walked poop a little bit
everywhere it's here it's here
what get it there [ __ ] I gotta get it
get it you get it it's here quick